[Musique]
les shadoks n'y avait pas de carburant
assez puissant pour faire partir le
refuser alors ils essayaient de pomper
le cosmo gun jbe à travers le cosmos et
s'imaginer que par la simple force
aspirante de leur machine
le cosmo gaulle consentirait à traverser
des espaces infinis du cosmos mais le
cosmo gaulle ne l'entendaient tout
simplement pas de cette oreille
des atomes de cosmo gun étaient des
atomes très lourd et très sérieux qui ne
changeait pas de planète comme ça pour
un oui pour un non et les dérisoires et
fort de ses pitoyables baisse n'avait
pratiquement aucun effet le cosmo gun
restaient suspendues dans le cosmos à
quelques encablures de la planète jbe
mais dès que les efforts des shadoks sur
la chaîne soit qu'ils à l'asse ou chez
soi qu'il combat à s'épuiser
le cos moghol repartait et tout était à
recommencer cercle et jbe qui était au
début de voir leurs atmosphères allait
venir comme ça sont rime ni raison alors
ils braquent air leurs antennes de
télévision et quand ils virent les
shadoks sur leur télévision une cure
plus inquiet du tout
il disait laissons faire les choses
de toute façon les shadoks sont idiots
leurs plans ratera et cetera et cetera
élus jpy décidèrent d'aller en vacances
à la campagne
en attendant que le plan shadow crac et
que les shadoks cela à ceux de pont pic
ceux qui ne pouvaient tarder
[Musique]